years of brutal civil war have ripped
Syria apart with horrific devastation to
its historical and archaeological
heritage hopeless no no future
nobody's looking forward for a future
your biggest hope is just finding food
for your kids whatever
but now refugees from the war are coming
together to learn an ancient craft
creating something beautiful and lasting
at the toughest of materials their hope
that one day they could return to their
homeland to use the skills of stone
masonry to help rescue their country's
shattered heritage and rebuild their
broken lives
[Music]
when you build something you start from
just signing a little bit and this is
the tiny little bit
[Music]
[Music]
like so many I watched the destruction
of homes lives and heritage in the war
zones of the Middle East with horror and
sorrow these are the lands I love
boasting unique ancient sites like this
um al Jamal just four miles from the
Syrian border in Jordan
built 2,000 years ago at a puzzled stone
for centuries it's been a crossroads of
cultures from all points of the compass
I've been traveling to as part of the
world for years because I'm drawn here
by the remarkable monuments and stories
left behind by some of the most vibrant
and energetic civilizations in human
history but I'm not just here to
investigate history because heritage
sites like these are in danger across
the region
[Music]
I've come to Jordan because I want to
see how in the desolation of war
the restoration of the past is bringing
rare hope for the future
[Music]
these are the outskirts of my frac just
over there there's a reception center
for Refugees but where I'm heading is
this modest little building now this was
originally the home of the International
Medical Corps but now it's a training
center and there's something rather
remarkable happening here
[Music]
[Music]
these students have been taught heritage
stonemasonry from scratch thanks to the
British councils cultural protection
fund in a project run by the World
Monuments fund this has to be one of the
most extraordinary of fine craft courses
[Music]
most of these students are dispossessed
refugees women men teenagers who've lost
their homes and fled Syria with nothing
and now creating architectural triumphs
[Music]
learning the skills which could one day
help rebuild their shattered land and a
third of the students are women tackling
a job which is traditionally being the
preserve of men for over a year the
project has been overseen by a
powerhouse so nobodies none of these
people have ever done this and so is the
idea that with these skills when they
can go back to Syria they'll be able to
work an important project it feels
because when we hear about Syria all we
hear about is destruction but here
something's being created nor is a
trained architectural engineer and
teaches the theory from geometry to
conservation and preservation techniques
while bara is the local project manager
but I have to say it's so impressive to
me that your two women running this
project it's brilliant
and also that you have so many women who
are training Estonia yes we have 1400
women's here housewife to reboot their
see the places and the the old cities
like like here in old Souq yes yes
because that's Aleppo yes there are says
the trips to heritage sites have
triggered a passion for the remnants of
the past all the time a student asked
why why this one's here why why they
both the skills to solve you they feel
something in the in the heart actually
you have a heart because we need to work
in the heritage places we need to to to
rebuild our countries I'm told two of
the most promising students are Khadija
and Ayesha they both fled from Syria at
the beginning of the war and were forced
to reconstruct their lives here from
scratch jebediah Cappadonna can
establish Cyril with a wali Tohono
Nikita reckon abuse now American
affiliate of Syria
van al Karbala see granny the Elwha had
the courage this mean the had some
foreign am barbados suffered such
ownership in santa ana laughter it
didn't select as I believe may lead them
and it left them in their own agendas
sharmeeli mechanical action in this
impoverished area local Jordanians have
been severely challenged by the crisis
at their borders
but here Jordanians and Syrians have
bonded and become close friends and
Khadija invites bra Laura me for a girl
Power Lunch Khadija and her young family
fled from Homs in Syria with nothing at
all except a few treasured photos of
happier times at the home they've lost
that's the only thing you brought with
you I thought you should have Egyptian
Charlotte Isabel of that a kid has a
nanny cam in heck Italian family anyway
it seems to me ladies that anyway you're
making history because it was very
unusual for there to be female
stonemasons
it must make you feel very proud of what
you've been doing I'm a proud of our
women the Syrian and Jordanian both
anonymous Abu be do any but the Jessa do
jihad victory okay she black shimmer our
aspect we do the anisotropy she and he
had be Magellan ahead inshallah thank
you
a number of the students tell me that
stone masonry has a therapeutic effect
[Music]
that it gives order and structure to
your day but the sound of the chisels is
hypnotic the work becomes a sole center
of your attention some become completely
absorbed in the work as if they're able
to lose themselves for a time
[Music]
working stone connects us to our
ancestors and to the skills and
experiences of others from different
ages and different places and for people
they've had almost everything taken from
them but have time it's also a way of
connecting to the future because stone
masonry crafts a kind of immortality
both for yourself and for your works
Hamza is from Damascus and came here in
his early teens he's become particularly
skilled in calligraphy spending hours
carefully carving Arabic scripts into
the finished stone the merciful merciful
yeah do you find when you're doing this
kind of thing that you feel connected to
the craftsmen and stonemasons who would
have done this 500 years ago exactly and
when you look at those things that they
built they're so so so beautiful so
amazing to look at they did it with
their hands so that's just you know
thinking about that is yeah amazing
amazing the process of creating
something absolutely beautiful something
that you can enjoy looking at can be
proud of that's the beginning of the
process you know of overcoming something
overcoming something that happened to
you in the past you know trying to do
something new
[Music]
no one at the school is under any
illusions about the scale of the task
ahead this is a video shown to students
just one terrible example of war damage
to Syria's historic monuments by the use
of drones and 3d scanners archeologists
have revealed the devastation to beit
Ghazali one of the largest ottoman era
palaces in aleppo the skills taught at a
stone masonry course in Jordan could
rebuild and restore every architectural
feature of this palace and others like
it perhaps just perhaps this offers a
glimmer of hope
[Music]
the lack of skilled stonemasons is a
serious cultural threads after the civil
war in Lebanon for instance many of the
historic buildings that were damaged
were simply bulldozed away and there's a
very real possibility that that might
well happen in Syria too which is why
this scheme it feels to me is fighting
the cause of the past the present and
the future
in the end it's not just about art but
about love love for archeology for the
legacy of the past and the power of
culture to bring people together helping
to find direction for the future and to
heal the wounds of the past
[Music]
you
you